day 11 the general election campaign and
somebody is like this to me it's a
document setting out the message and
speeches and interviews for over 600
conservative candidates and it was only
sent last week and as usual stuff chaos
competence long term plans while
striking about it is a sheer number of
references to Ed Miliband 99 references
in just 88 pages compared to just 10
references to David Cameron so some data
evidence proof if you like of the
negativity of the conservative campaign
added to this from this morning the
backstabber quote from the defense
secretary about Ed Miliband on Trident
and on his brother nobody surprised
we've known that the strategy of the
conservative two months have been our
economic competence and leadership labor
can indulge in negativity of their own
about the conservative leadership so
forget the morals for a second the
question arising tonight's from a shock
poll from servation and the Daily Mirror
showing Ed Miliband ahead on approval
ratings after that non dawn policy
announcement the question really is is
negative campaigning actually working